geek news a real-life superhero exists
in Manchester England huh Manchester
England England when I say that city's
name because that happens his name's
Roger Hayhurst by day he's a
mild-mannered gardener but by night he
transforms himself into the night
warrior he is one of the latest craze of
real-life superheroes who are going
about protecting it's the KNI Jay and I
say yeah ni ght yes
he's 19 years old he says he breaks up
fights and cracks down on anti-social
behavior so what if people are just like
that movie sucks he's like no citizen me
those artists work hard oh [ __ ] I want
one of them I would support the creative
arts instead of bashing them how could
you do anything better yes that's what I
need a paid superhero to go to every
[ __ ] movie I make sit there when
people start bashing on just feel like
now you didn't quite think this through
look at how hard all those kids worked
don't be an [ __ ] this won't come as a
shock to you he asked no secret lair
because he still lives with his mom and
his name man [ __ ] Batman lives in his
parents house too
yeah that they were dead and rich he
also lives with his granddad Alfred oh
the Batphone sir I brought a little
video of Roger God loved him he's a
sweet kid you could tell he's his
heart's in the right place but he's got
the worst ass lycra costume we've ever
seen anything but he's just he's just
kind of tragic so here's a little video
of Roger haters the night warrior from
Manchester I do this because I'm sick of
people standing by and doing nothing and
they really want to have fun the
community and you get a lot of stick
from people but most people watching
people being held from the mirror
supportive
he says he mostly breaks up fights
outside of pubs Rogers gonna get his ass
kicked
could you imagine you're like shit-faced
outside some British club and some
[ __ ] trying to [ __ ] turn you out
mate and awesome this dudes like stop
citizens
I really think you two should stop it
become tired of people going around not
caring what happens in the community so
if you two could just work out your
differences by talking punch you in your
[ __ ] face you bounce now hold on a
second I really think it's better if
everyone just talks to their problems up
and does not resort to fun could you
help me pick up my teeth all over the
floor Roger says when people see me
coming up it does tend to stun them into
silence followed by uproarious laughter
it doesn't add but I'm assuming
[Music]
you